ses glacières contiennent le précieux
vaccin anti qu'ovide 1200 dos du
laboratoire chinois sinovac ont été
livrés à l'île de pâques les tout
premiers ces roms ont été injectés ce
lundi aux habitants de plus de 80 ans
mais aussi au personnel et médical eh
bien je viens d'être vacciné contre le
colis de 19 avec la première dose il y
avait un protocole assez strictes pour
pouvoir se faire vacciner
en tout cas ça le fait pas du tout de
mal il n'y a pas d'effets indésirables
on passe environ 30 minutes pour voir si
une sensation une tachycardie
mais ici on parlait tous joyeusement
donc je vous invite tous à vous faire
vacciner sans vent d'eau seulement vous
pu être administré ce lundi pour le
maire de l'île de pâques les règles
imposées par santiago freine la campagne
de vaccination comment se fait-il que le
calendrier de vaccination ne donne la
priorité aux personnes âgées de 85 à 90
ans qui sont au nombre de 5 et 6,5
que faire alors avec le reste des
vaccins doit j'attends la semaine
prochaine
l'île de pâques doit recevoir au total
seize mille doses au laboratoire chinois
sinovac
les autorités espèrent vacciner 8000
personnes soit 80 % la population aucun
cas de coronavirus n'a été recensé
depuis plus de trois cent dix jours sur
ce territoire chilien au milieu du
pacifique
les autorités locales ont décidé
d'isoler totalement le continent pour
préserver les habitants le tourisme est
pourtant le principal moyen de
subsistance de l'île de pâques des rapa
nui ont d'ailleurs célébré la semaine
dernière leur traditionnel festival
tapati cents visiteurs pour la toute
première fois le prix à payer peut-être
pour vivre sur une île kovy de free sans
toutes les contraintes sanitaires que
connaît quasiment le reste du monde